Hallo zusammen!
Wir machen heute ein richtig leckeres arabisch angehauchtes Rezept aber ich bin heute nicht alleine!
Zu Gast ist bei mir ein - ich würde mal sagen TikToker, der sehr, sehr gerne kocht
und es schafft, Rezepte irgendwie innerhalb von 60sek vorzustellen, was ich mir gar nicht vorstellen kann!
Hier ist Can!
Ta-da!
Der Weg ist ein bisschen lang, er braucht ein bisschen!
[Can] Was geht?
[Kiki] Hi! Schön, dass du hier bist!
Stell dich gerne kurz mal in 2 Sätzen vor!
2 Sätze, okay. Ich bin Can und ich koche gern!
[Can] Waren das 2 Sätze?
[Kiki] Okay, cool!
Hättest auch noch einen dritten hinzufügen können, wir sind jetzt hier nicht so streng! Nein!
Also das ist Can, wir haben uns jetzt - wir sehen uns heute das erste Mal.
Ich find's cool, dass du gekommen bist! Super spontan angeschrieben: "Hast du Lust?"
Und wir kochen heute Shawarma und quatschen so ein bisschen über die TikTok-Welt..
ein bisschen Real Talk, ein bisschen über dich!
Und..hast du eine Schokoseite oder ist es egal?
[Can] Eine Schokoseite?
[Kiki] Ja!
Ähm ja..nicht, dass ich wüsste!
Okay ich hab eine deswegen lass uns mal Plätze tauschen!
Ja okay!
Nee, ich hab mir überlegt du kannst die Kartoffeln schälen.
[Can] Yes!
[Kiki] Weil wir machen das so typisch, ne? Shawarma mit..
[Can] Pommes!
[Kiki] Salat!
[Kiki] Pommes!
[Can] Yes!
[Hamza] Also innen drin ist Pommes!
Innen drin ist Pommes und nochmal nebenbei! Nebenbei geht auch immer!
Deswegen gebe ich dir die Kartoffeln.
Wir machen das jetzt freestyle-mäßig wie wir unser Hähnchen würzen. Ich hab das jetzt schon vorgeschnitten.
Was würdest du reinmachen? Guck mal in die Gewürzschublade!
Komm, mach ein paar Gewürze raus einfach! Müsste alles da haben.
[Can] Zimt, ganz wenig Zimt.
[Kiki] Zimt! Okay, interessant!
Mach ich gern zu Hackfleisch aber interessant!
[Hamza] Also das ist jetzt dein Rezept?
Ja ich hab's tatsächlich vor 3 Tagen selber gekocht.
Also wenn du ganz wenig Zimt reinmachst, dann kriegst du dieses leicht süßliche
Ahh, geil!
Und ich kann's z.B. meiner Mama nicht erzählen weil die gar keinen Zimt mag aber du schmeckst es halt eigentlich gar nicht raus.
[Kiki] Okay, hört sich gut an!
[Can] Ja, Sumak auf jeden Fall.
Oh Sumak liebe ich, auch auf Salat!
[Kiki] Liebe ich über alles, ja!
[Can] Oder auch so auf geschnittenen Zwiebeln!
[Can] Paprika auf jeden Fall, Kümmel..
[Kiki] Pul biber?
Dann würze ich das Hähnchen, dann lassen wir das - eigentlich wär cool glaub ich es 3-4h richtig marinieren zu lassen -
wir machen heute ½h draus. Ihr Zuhause könnt's auch..
[Kiki] Man könnt's auch eigentlich am Vortag machen und dann richtig durchziehen lassen!
[Can] Ja, abends!
Aber wir haben Hunger, ne? Wir haben noch nicht gefrühstückt!
Okay! Ich mariniere, du machst die Pommes fertig und dann quatschen wir solange!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Can] Yes!
Ja, es ist für mich eine ungewohnte Küche aber ich werd' mich auf jeden Fall noch zurechtfinden!
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall gute Qualität, ne? Ist nicht kaputt gegangen!
Nee, kann ich nur weiterempfehlen! Yes!
Aber was mir passiert ist mit genau dem Teil - Ich hab's gründlich gewaschen, keine Sorge! -
Ich hab mir richtig in den Nagel rein - also richtig den Nagel weggehauen!
Und daher muss ich heute mit Pflaster kochen!
[Can] Der Schnitt verheilt doch auch nicht, das dauert immer voll lang!
[Kiki] Ich weiß!
Bei dem Ding ist es, der schneidet von beiden Seiten!
Aaah!
[Can] Ich fang schonmal an einfach!
[Kiki] Joa!
Also kurz zu dir: Du machst ja TikTok, du machst seit..wie vielen Monaten TikTok?
Ich hab als wir ins Home Office geschickt wurden alle, hab ich angefangen, Videos hochzuladen.
Und es ist eigentlich ganz lustig weil ich eigentlich gar keine Kochvideos hochladen wollte sondern komplett andere Videos.
Und es gab mal so eine Challenge - Also auf TikTok gibt's ja verschiedene Challenges -
die hieß "Selber Kochen", das heißt da waren halt verschiedene Kochvideos.
Und es war halt irgendwie so ein Samstag und ich wach so auf und ich denk mir:
Ich hab das halt so gesehen: "Das kann ich auch!"
[Kiki] Ja, cool!
[Can] Also ich koch doch auch, ne?
Ich koche eigentlich schon sehr, sehr gerne aber ich hab' das Video halt lustlos aufgenommen
weil ich mir dachte: "Ja okay, dann lad ich jetzt auch ein Video hoch!"
Ich war auch komplett unzufrieden damit.
Das ist immer so beim ersten Video!
Plötzlich mach ich so irgendwann mein Handy an und das hat irgendwie so 30.000 Views oder so!
Krass, direkt viral gegangen!
Ja, anscheinend! Also ich wusste ja da gar nicht, was überhaupt "viral gehen" heißt!
Also ich komme überhaupt nicht aus der Social Media Welt.
Aktualisiere ich.. 40.000 Views... 60.000 Views!
Und ich denk mir so: "Hä, was?!"
Kraaass!
Ich dachte mir: "Warum guckt ihr das an? Das ist zu schlecht! Das ist - guckt das nicht an!"
[Hamza] Du hast dich geschämt für deinen Content oder was?
Anscheinend war's auch lustig, ich hab Suçuk mir Ei gemacht.
[Kiki] Ja?
[Can] Und macht sich so..
Aber das ist es glaub ich, ne? Das ist dieses klassische Suçuk mit Ei, leicht!
[Hamza] Das mach ich alle 3 Tage!
"Ah okay! Das ist etwas, das dir Spaß macht und anscheinend scheint's den Leuten zu gefallen. Dann mach das doch!"
Seitdem hab ich tatsächlich einfach jeden Tag Kochvideos hochgeladen von mir.
Keinen Tag ausgelassen oder..?
Nein. Also es gibt keinen Tag, wo ich nix poste.
Krass!
Das ist wie wenn man sich vorm Schlafengehen die Zähne nicht putzt!
[Kiki] Es ist Routine!
[Can] Jaja, genau!
[Hamza] Das ist wie so eine Serie, die man jeden Tag guckt!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Can] Ja, genau!
[Hamza] So Anime! *lacht*
[Kiki] Ja, ist echt so!
Hast du denn feste Uploadzeiten? So jeden Tag um 10h kommt dann ein TikTok?
Nee, absolut gar nicht!
Okay, das heißt da hast du so ein bisschen die Lockerheit, bisschen die Freiheit..
Du musst ja nicht alles strukturiert planen!
Ich glaub das ist auch Druck und ja, dann merkt man das auch irgendwann in den Videos denke ich.
Ich hab jetzt ein bisschen Olivenöl reingemacht.
Sollen wir noch ein bisschen Joghurt oder sagst du lieber -
Obwohl du so ein Joghurtfreak bist! Wenn man dir auf TikTok folgt, weiß man: Du isst einfach alles mit Joghurt!
Safe!
Sollen wir da auch Joghurt reinmachen oder sagst du: "Heute mal lieber nicht"?
Ich glaub weil wir das ja eh nicht so lange marinieren bringt's glaub ich nichts, wenn wir da Joghurt drauf machen, oder?
Im Endeffekt kann's eh nicht so reinziehen wie wir's möchten, ne?
Ja, das ist das Ding!
Presst du auch Knoblauch? Schneidest du die?
Ich - Manchmal zerhacke ich den.
Wenn ich das hier reinmachen würde, dann würd' ich das zerreiben aufgrund dessen, dass ich meine Knoblauchpresse nicht mehr finde.
Achso, okay!
Hamza hast du zufällig noch 'ne Knoblauchpresse grad mitgenommen ausm Shop?
[Hamza] Jaa!
Sehr gut! Dann hast du ab jetzt wieder eine!
[Can] Ach krass!
[Kiki] Ich hol mal meine kurz raus!
[Hamza] Der hat's noch nicht verstanden!
Es gibt immer Team Hacken, Team Pressen.
Einige sagen wenn du es presst, ist der Geschmack ganz anders.
[Kiki] Ich hab da bis jetzt noch keinen Unterschied gemerkt!
[Can] Ja, ich auch nicht!
[Hamza] Knoblauch ist auch wirklich so intensiv vom Geschmack, das merkt man glaub ich gar nicht!
Also was musst du für ein kranker Feinschmecker sein? Ich bin ja -
Ich finde, ich bin schon ein Feinschmecker. Du mit Sicherheit auch.
Ich krieg dann auch oft Ärger von meiner Mutter wenn ich sage:
"Da fehlt das und das und das und das!"
[Hamza] *lacht*
Ja, eine Mama möchte das nicht hören. Für die Mama soll alles einfach perfekt sein!
[Hamza] Meine Mutter würde mir nie wieder Suppe kochen dann!
Ich weiß ja - vielleicht schmecke ich das ja auch falsch raus und mein Geschmackssinn hat sich einfach so entwickelt, dass ich das will!
Also vielleicht fehlt ja nicht Paprika aber ich bin's gewohnt, viel Paprika zu essen so!
Ich find diese ganzen Kochshows ein bisschen - also es gibt ja immer diese Challenges:
Ein Team kocht und dann probiert einer, der diesen einen individuellen Geschmack hat.
Ja, Gordon Ramsay!
Ja! Und ich denk mir so: Aber wer sagt denn, das es jetzt nicht jemand anders schmeckt?
[Can] Ja, das ist das Ding!
[Kiki] Also das ist schon ein bisschen tricky find ich!
Ich brauch 'n Messer!
Ähm - oder..oder!
[Kiki] Ich gebe dir..
[Can] Okay, jetzt kommt's!
...unseren Wellenschneider!
[Hamza] Präsentier das mal so richtig!
[Kiki]Unseren..Ta-da, Wellenschneider!
[Hamza] Ta-da!
[Can] Krass!
[Kiki] Ich weiß nicht, ob du das selber benutzt aber das Ding ist heftig!
Alles, was du damit schneidest, sieht leckerer aus,
nimmt Soßen besser auf durch die Rillen
und du kannst halt auch richtig schöne Spalten damit schneiden!
[Kiki] Einfach so reinhauen!
[Can] Echt?
Da kannst du dich auch gar nicht dran schneiden!
[Can] Also ich hau das jetzt einfach so da rein?
[Kiki] Genau, hau das einfach da durch!
[Can] Zack! Krass!
[Kiki] Ja, perfekt!
Du wirst merken: Es wird schmackhafter aussehen!
[Kiki] Genauso wie Toast in Dreiecke zu schneiden!
[Can] Safe!
Das ist auch einfach leckerer!
Das ist Premium! Da hast du so Zuhause ein Luxusessen und wenn du das im Viereck hast, hast du so..
Ja, dann ist das so..
Ich glaube auch, dass - Du schneidest ja hier Rillen rein
siehst du, dadurch öffnest du halt die Oberfläche.
Das heißt wenn du's gleich würzt oder frittierst, dann nimmt das die Oberfläche einfach viel eher an.
[Kiki]Definitv, definitiv! Auch wenn du das in so ne Soße tunkst, das haftet viel besser!
[Can] Safe, ja!
Du hast aber trotzdem noch einen YouTube Kanal, wo du auch relativ regelmäßig was hochlädst.
Regelmäßig ist so eine Sache. Als ich jünger war, wollte ich immer YouTuber werden.
Aber ich hab's dann irgendwann nicht gemacht weil ich glaub' jeder, der 14 Jahre alt ist oder so will irgendwann mal YouTuber werden. Also ich kenn viele!
[Hamza] Oder Feuerwehrmann!
Das, was früher der Feuerwehrmann war!
Schnell merkt man: Das ist ja doch ein bisschen mehr Arbeit, als einfach nur Videos hochzuladen!
Dann hatte ich das halt irgendwann aufgehört. Dann dachte ich mir: "Hey, warum machst du's nicht weiter?"
und hab das dann weitergemacht. Allerdings fokussiere ich mich eher auf TikTok.
Die Leute können das wirklich nachmachen! Das ist nicht nur so: "Ahja, mach mal den Schritt!" und irgendwann kommt dann schon der über-über-nächste
sondern du machst das so, dass die Leute das auch wirklich nachmachen können.
Das ist echt krass! Also ich denke immer:
"Niemals auf dieser Welt wird doch" - das ist eigentlich dumm, wenn man das als Creator selber denkt -
Aber ich denke mir: "Das macht doch niemals jemand nach!"
Und wenn man dann so Nachrichten bekommt, dass - Bilder bekommt, dass das echt jemand nachmacht!
Das schmeichelt - also ich find das voll krass!
Das bedeutet nämlich, dass dir jemand vertraut.
Und wenn man dann einmal enttäuscht ist - man verliert das Vertrauen!
Du stellst dich hierhin und das zeigt halt: Ey, der vertraut dir echt! Und wenn's dann klappt, dann ist das halt mega nice!
[Hamza] Ich glaub das ist auch das Erfolgsgeheimnis von Kiki! Also dass es bei ihr immer funktioniert.
Ja, das ist super wichtig. Gelingsicherheit ist super wichtig!
[Kiki] Die Leute kaufen ein, sie geben Geld aus..]
[Can] Ja!
Noch viel schlimmer: Sie geben Zeit aus!
Was mir aufgefallen ist - Kurz für euch: Darüber haben Can und ich uns gerade mal als die Kameras noch aus waren unterhalten.
[Kiki] TikTok ist wie du gesagt hast eine familiäre Plattform, ne?
[Can] Ja, safe!
Und ihr habt alle mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig gestartet. Vor allem während dann der Lockdown war Anfang des Jahres.
Mir ist aufgefallen, - mal Real Talk - dass bei TikTok wirklich diese familiäre Atmosphäre herrscht
und gerade YouTube Deutschland ist relativ missgönnerisch.
[Kiki] Also es ist mir tatsächlich echt aufgefallen..
[Hamza] Also die sind nicht offen gegenüber anderen!
Die sind überhaupt nicht offen. Also gerade so ameri- Guckst du amerikanisches YouTube?
[Can] Ja, sehr oft. Also vor allem Food-YouTube.
[Kiki] Ja, ich auch. Mag ich total!
Mir ist aufgefallen als ich mal auf Instagram gesurft habe, hab ich gesehen:
Der eine große YouTuber supportet den, der vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner ist.
Die kommentieren untereinander.
Und das finde ich, fehlt mir so ein bisschen bei YouTube Deutschland.
Das ist total schade und ich glaube dafür ist TikTok eine coole Plattform.
Safe!
Jeder zieht an einem Strang und deshalb hab ich auch gedacht ich möchte auf TikTok jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr machen.
Da sind einfach sehr viele junge Leute, die jetzt nicht seit 8 Jahren YouTube machen
und schon abgestumpft sind was die ganzen Erfahrungen angehen.
Leute, die plötzlich nichts mit Social Media zu tun hatten, auf einmal ein paar 100.000 Follower haben
und noch gar nicht dieses: "Oh, ich brauch jetzt ein Management" und "Ah, du hast mir auf Instagram geschrieben, schreib mal bitte erstmal Management an!" oder so.
Und ich guck mir ja selber Videos an. Dann sehe ich ein Video uns ich kommentier's
und andere kommentieren da drunter: "Waas?! Du bist auch hier?"
Auf jeden Fall! Und das fehlt auf YouTube!
Also das ist auf TikTok, was auf YouTube eben überhaupt nicht gegeben ist.
Also TikTok ist für mich eine sehr ehrliche, offenherzige Plattform.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob - Ich sprech mal jetzt direkt zur Kikimunity - ob ihr auf TikTok seid!
Schreibt's vielleicht jetzt mal in die Kommentare: Habt ihr einen Account?
Ich lese auch zwischendurch mal: "Hey Kiki, ich hab gar kein Instagram!"
Ich finde Instagram ist so eine Plattform, die hat eigentlich irgendwie wirklich jeder mittlerweile.
Denkt man, denkt man!
[Kiki] Ist das gar nicht so?
[Can] Nee!
Ich bekomm auch manchmal Kommentare, wo die Leute schreiben: "Ich seh deine Stories gar nicht weil ich bin nicht auf Instagram!"
Aber schreibt mir mal jetzt in die Kommentare: Habt ihr TikTok?
Oder überlegt ihr's vielleicht ob ihr euch da jetzt anmeldet?
Dann verlinke ich euch definitiv mal Cans Account und auch meinen.
Und ich würd sagen: Also das ist jetzt, das Hähnchen ist jetzt soweit fertig.
[Can] Ich brauch noch ein bisschen! Ich hab hier..
[Kiki] Ja, mach du ganz in Ruhe!
[Can] ..ein neues Werkzeug, mit dem ich..
[Kiki] Ja, tob dich aus!
Wir haben die jetzt in kaltem Wasser quasi einmal "eingelegt" sage ich mal damit die ganze Stärke rausgeht.
Unbedingt abtupfen damit ihr das später dann ins heiße Öl geben könnt
und wenn noch Wasser dran ist, spritzt das durch die ganze Küche.
Und danach würd' ich sagen können wir schon direkt das Fleisch anbraten, ne?
Das - genau, das frittieren wir und das Fleisch braten wir an.
Und das ist eigentlich auch schon die meiste Arbeit, ne? Und danach sind wir auch schon fast fertig!
Magen knurrt schon!
Also! Wie wir hier sehen, haben wir unsere Pommes frittiert.
Wir haben unser Fleisch vorbereitet, unsere Soße fast vorbereitet!
Da fehlt ja noch offensichtlich das eine oder andere.
Jaa! Du haste ne coole Idee gehabt. Ich wollt' dich nicht unterbrechen aber du hast 'ne richtig geile Idee gehabt!
Ich sag zu Can: "Ich hol die Mayo raus und so, dann machen wir so eine Mayo-Knoblauch Soße!"
Und er meinte: "Nein, es muss safe Joghurt sein!" weil du bist ja so ein Joghurtfreak!
[Can] Ich liebe es!
[Kiki] Ich find' die Idee richtig geil! Dann ist es nochmal schön fettarm!
Genau! Vor allem: es ist finde ich der optimale Ersatz für Mayonnaise und man fühlt sich nicht so schlecht nach dem Essen.
Hast vollkommen recht!
[Kiki]Da kommt ganz viel Knoblauch rein..
[Can] Yes!
Spritzer Zitronensaft, Salz, Olivenöl... Hast du noch eine Idee, was wir reintun könnten?
Oder ist es so vollkommen?
Ich find's so auf jeden Fall sehr gut!
[Kiki] Weniger ist mehr!
[Can] Ja!
[Kiki] Und die ganzen Gewürze haben wir auch schon im Fleisch.
[Can] Ganz genau!
Was machst du jetzt an die Pommes noch? Ganz klassisch Salz oder..?
Ach die sind ja noch gar nicht gesalzen, ne? Das ist - oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh! Die müssen auf jeden Fall noch gesalzen werden!
Ja! Wir haben hier glaub ich Salz und Pfeffer, oder?
[Can] Das ist Salz - das ist Salz, das ist Pfeffer..
[Hamza] Oben steht's drauf!
Achja! So!
Dann kann ich dich ja mit Fragen jetzt weiter durchlöchern!
Ja. Aber ganz kurz, ich hab mal 'ne Frage: Es ist doch normal, auf Pommes Pfeffer zu tun, oder?
Klar! Wer behauptet das Gegenteil?
Ja, schon öfter Leute in meinen Kommentaren.
[Kiki] Ehrlich?!
[Hamza] Ich glaube das sind jüngere Zuschauer, die dann denken es ist zu scharf.
[Kiki] Wahrscheinlich!
[Can] Aber Pfeffer ist ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht scharf!
Nee, eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Aber richtiger Fun Fact gerade!
Wie ich überhaupt so auf Can über TikTok kam:
Ich scroll so durch, auf einmal sehe ich so den Can, wie er so Pommes zubereitet.
Deswegen cool, dass wir auch heute Pommes gemacht haben!
Und dann gibt's so diese Duettfunktion bei TikTok.
Ich reagier so drauf, ruf den Hamza noch dazu. Das können wir gleich mal einblenden!
Und am Ende tunkst du so deine Pommes in Joghurt!
Ich dacht so: "Hä? Was ist mit dem nicht richtig?"
Und ja, das kam mir so komisch vor! Würdet ihr's genauso machen oder einfach nur Ketchup, Mayo?
Das soll mal jeder in die Kommentare schreiben, ob das nicht das Beste ist, was man machen kann!
[Hamza] Aber Bratkartoffeln isst man ja auch mit so 'ner Joghurtsoße, oder?
Eigentlich ja! Aber irgendwie so Bratkartoffel von der Form her fänd' ich normaler mit Joghurt zu essen und das kam mir so komisch vor!
Aber wenn man sich 'nen Dönerteller bestellt, kriegt man dann Mayonnaise oder kriegt man Joghurtsoße?
Hops genommen! Ich kann nichts mehr sagen!
[Hamza] Also ich würd' Mayo nehmen!
So! Eigentlich müssten wir jetzt nur noch zusammenstellen. Wir haben ja da auch -
So ganz typisch sind ja saure Gurken, ein bisschen Salat und jetzt stellen wir uns einfach zusammen.
Und ganz klassisch: Die Pommes müssen auch noch eingerollt werden!
[Kiki] So, wir rollen endlich zusammen!
[Can] Yes!
Und zwar nimmt man dafür ganz klassisch dieses arabische/libanesische Fladenbrot, ne?
Und ich würd' einfach mal sagen du kannst frei Schnauze belegen! Ich geb' dir mal die Soße.
Ich würd's so belegen, dass ich erst mal ein bisschen Joghurt nehme.
Die Soße vorher drauf zu tun hat den Vorteil, dass wir schon mal die Soße drauf haben!
Boah, ich dacht da kommt jetzt so 'ne richtige Pointe!
Das ist so typisch Arabisch, typisch Türkisch auch, Pommes einfach nochmal mit da rein zu geben.
Wenn man sich bei Mc Donald's einen Burger holt, immer in den Burger Pommes reinmachen!
Das hab ich früher auch immer gemacht. Das mach ich auch heute noch wenn ich selber Burger mache oder so. Ich hau mir auch immer meine Kartoffeln da rein!
Hey du hast mal bei Mc Donald's gearbeitet, kann das sein?
[Can] Ja, hab ich.
[Kiki] Wie lange?
[Can] Äh, einen Tag.
[Kiki] Einen Tag?!
[Can] So richtig einen Tag, ja.
[Kiki] Okay! Was war los? Haben die dich rausgescheucht oder was?
Ich bin 18 Jahre alt geworden und hatte mir ein Auto gekauft und musste ja irgendwie das Auto bezahlen!
Okay, was ist dann passiert?
Ich hab da dann einen Tag gearbeitet. Es war auch am Anfang sehr spannend
aber es war für mich die absolute Hölle, dort zu arbeiten weil ich hab' den ganzen Tag Cheeseburger, Hamburger und Big Macs gemacht.
[Can] Den ganzen Tag!
[Kiki] Wie viel Stunden waren's?
8 Stunden! Und du stehst so auf deinen Beinen und dieses Piepen, das jeder kennt. Dieses Mc Donald's Piepen..
Du kommst nachhause und es geht dir nicht aus dem Kopf! Deine Haut fühlt sich so fettig an.
Achso, das Fett zieht so richtig vom Grill in die Haut?
Ja, und dann gehen ja diese Burgerdinger auf. Diese Maschinen, ne?
...unten auf deine Haut noch Fett! Weißt du, wie viele Brandwunden..?
Nein!!
Ja und dann sagt der: "Ich hab viel mehr als du, voll normal!"
Nee Mann, alter! Ich kann das nicht, ich will das nicht machen!
Also nicht, dass ich nicht arbeiten möchte aber ich hab mir halt etwas gesucht, was mir eher liegt.
[Can] Dann hab ich gelogen..
[Hamza] Dann bist du zu Burger King gegangen!
Genau, dann bin ich zu Burger King gegangen!
Also ich hatt' da noch nicht die Eier, zu sagen oder den Mumm zu sagen. Dann hab ich halt gesagt: "Ja, wir ziehen um!"
Einfach: "Wir ziehen um, ciao!"
Ja!
Das sieht schonmal sehr lecker aus! Wie rollst du das zusammen, hast du da einen besonderen Trick?
Ich weiß nicht, ob's authentisch ist aber ich würd' die Ecke hier geschwind zuklappen damit da auch nichts rausrollt..
Einmal so hierhin klappen und jetzt - Ich ess es ja sowieso, ich mach's jetzt ein bisschen mit meinen Händen.
Und presse das hier alles zusammen, rolle das zusammen.
..grillen oder braten würde, dann wird das hier fest und wir haben hier schön unsere Rillen und es ist perfekt!
Das machen wir jetzt, ich hol jetzt 'ne Pfanne. Rillen hab ich leider nicht! Ich weiß was du meinst aber dafür haben wir Rillen in unseren Pommes!
Perfekt!
Nehmen wir da einfach..die Pfanne ist ja glaub ich heiß, ne?
Ja!
Ich würd's jetzt einfach so braten.
[Kiki]Okay, von beiden Seiten einfach so ein paar Minuten?
[Can] Yes!
Jetzt hab' ich mal 'ne Frage an dich. Wenn TikTok dir sagt - Du hast ja jetzt einen Vollzeit-Job, du arbeitest 40h die Woche -
Wenn TikTok jetzt sagt: "Ey nächsten Monat kriegst du jeden Monat 5.000€ Gehalt auf dein Konto, mach einfach deinen Content weiter!"
Würdest du deinem Chef sagen: "Ciao, ich mach nix mehr"?
Dann.. ich wär' auf den Malediven! Nein Spaß!
Das, was ich hier mache ist das, was mir sehr viel Spaß macht und was für mich eine Leidenschaft ist.
Ich würde sagen: "Ich werde für ein paar Monate oder für ein paar Jahre versuchen ein Projekt, was mir sehr am Herzen liegt, zu verfolgen und ich werd das nicht mehr machen."
Ich bezweifle, dass es irgendjemand mir übel nehmen würde, dass ich einen - Traum würde ich jetzt nicht so krass sagen -
aber etwas gefunden habe, das mir Spaß macht. Warum sollte ich nicht versuchen, damit Geld zu verdienen und das Ziel auch zu verfolgen?
Wenn mir jemand 5.000e geben möchte...
Ich schreib euch die Kontaktdaten unten rein!
Nee cool! Nein, find ich cool! Dass du auch sagen würdest, du hast jetzt was für dich gefunden
und so ist es ja eigentlich auch bei uns. Wir haben einfach angefangen genauso wie du.
Plötzlich entwickelt sich eine Leidenschaft, man bleibt dran..
Es gibt mit Sicherheit Menschen auf der Welt, die können besser kochen und backen als du und ich und die machen kein Social Media.
Wichtig ist, dass man diszipliniert dranbleibt.
Jeden Tag ein TikTok Video rauszuhauen  ist mit Sicherheit nicht einfach.
Genauso wie wir jede Woche 2 YouTube Videos raushauen.
[Can] Safe!
[Kiki] Es ist die Disziplin, die es dann am Ende ausmacht.
Wie lange brauchst du für ein TikTok Video, was 60sek geht?
Boah, also ich koch ja ein Gericht und..
Also wenn wir jetzt dieses Gericht hier gemacht haben..wir sind ja jetzt hier ein, zwei, drei Stündchen jetzt dran.
[Can] Genauso lange dauert es ja auch am Ende des Tages.
[Kiki] Ach krass!
Viele vergessen, dass es ja damit aufhört: Du drehst ja nicht ein Video und setzt dich danach hin.
Also danach schneidest du das, dass es ja auch völlig verständlich ist, dass es auch jeder nachvollziehen kann.
Und deswegen versuche ich eigentlich so viel wie möglich für Leute, denen mein Content gefällt, da zu sein.
Sehr schön! Sehr schöne Worte! Ehrlichkeit ist so mitunter das Wichtigste.
Vor allem beim Essen!
Das Geile ist wenn man das jetzt in der Pfanne angebraten hat, ne?
Wenn's jetzt wirklich so ist, wie ich es mir denke: Das hat sich hier geschlossen!
Also ich hab Hunger!
[Kiki] Ich auch, ich auch!
[Can] Safe, ne?
Wir haben's jetzt 17 Uhr. Wir drehen hier seit 7-8h aber so ist das!
[Kiki] Und wir probieren jetzt! Du nimmst..?
[Can] Ich nehm' den!
[Can] Taste Test!
[Kiki] Taste Test! Oh mein Gott, ich bin so aufgeregt!
Mmh!
Fresh!
[Hamza] Alles gut, esst ruhig!
Viel Knoblauch, sehr viel Knoblauch!
Aber wenn man's mag ist es geil! Ich mag Knoblauch.
Das ist unnormal lecker. Ey dieses Gefühl, wenn man den ganzen Tag nichts gegessen hat ist einfach das Beste, was es gibt!
Wie fasten!
[Hamza] Ja, ich find's auch lecker!
Komm, der andere ist für dich! Wir machen auch noch ein paar, wir haben ja noch mehrere.
Ah übrigens: Ich schreibe euch alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Und ansonsten Can: Lass einfach mal richtig gönnen jetzt, uns hinsetzen, Cola dazu!
Ich schreib' euch auf jeden Fall Cans Social Media Kanäle unten in die Videobeschreibung.
[Kiki]Unbedingt folgen, ein Like da lassen, abchecken!
[Can] Safe!
Ja, hat mich sehr gefreut, dass du heute dabei warst!
Es war für mich eine Ehre. Es hat wirklich super Spaß gemacht!
[Kiki] Uns auch!
[Can] Für mich was voll Neues!
[Hamza] Wie vergleichst du uns, TikTok zu YouTube?
Das ist wie wenn du plötzlich nach Hollywood fährst in so 'ne Hollywood-Produktion! Es ist echt 'ne andere Welt einfach!
Ja, cool. Schönes Fazit!
Wir machen meine Standard-Verabschiedung!
Wir sehen uns bei meinem nächsten Video! Tschüüss!
[Kiki] Also du musst dann so machen!
[Can] Tschüüss!
Okay, nochmal bei 3!
Also, bis zum nächsten Video!
*beide* Tschüüss!